europa ha superado la barrera de un
millón de decesos desde el inicio de la
pandemia el conjunto de 52 países
sobrepasó la cifra el lunes a causa del
aumento del 5% muertes en los últimos 2
meses a nivel mundial
el anuncio llegaba a la vez que la oms
se advertía que es un momento crítico de
la pandemia destacaba la importancia de
no centrarse únicamente en las vacunas
la semana pasada un aumento del 9% en
los contagios la séptima semana
consecutiva en la que vemos un aumento
en la transmisión y un aumento del 5% en
muertes esta no es la dirección en la
que debemos ir si tenemos que ser serios
al respecto y se trata de las vacunas
pero no solo de las vacunas sino de las
vacunas y a lo que podemos hacer para
mantenerte a salvo a ti y a tus seres
queridos en la región se registran
distintas tendencias epidemiológicas y
ritmos de vacunación en reino unido se
encuentran en un momento más
esperanzador en el que el gobierno ha
decidido relajar las restricciones por
su avance en la vacunación pero en
francia a pesar de haber aumentado el
ritmo de la vacunación
de contagios sigue alto con casi 6.000
pacientes en cuidados intensivos por su
parte alemania ya ha superado el umbral
de 3 millones de contagios la canciller
angela merkel dijo que la tercera ola
podría ser la más dura el uso de las
unidades de cuidado intensivo en
nuestros hospitales está aumentando de
nuevo y debemos decir que la tercera ola
puede resultar la más dura para nosotros
la canciller dijo considerar necesario
un toque de queda para las regiones con
mayor incidencia del virus sin embargo
recalcó que la vacuna ofrece una luz al
final del túnel para alemania